Oh, newcomer, I slept well. Good morning, my mother.
That senior, run this
way.
Hey, that
kind of monster a
Messer,
I'll specially guide you through a certain black cow's super astringent road, yeah
Infrared Twister,
Parry Kursan Senpai, a senior who doesn't roll up with a penny-bow shape,
I need a total of 6 bokeh along the Okawa River
I love this place
ah ah ah
Singing in the cold all
right o It's a
hot black sidestream It's not as hot as this 0
7 How do you get out
yeah
If it gets in, I'll use trap magic a
And it's about the toilet
Ingenuity
[Music]
There are already 10
more people
Morning hoi
Creatures get wet before singing,
hey It's a very honorable job I
really don't want to give it up Let's smoke outside
Feeding  Mukaida-san in the
shallows Oh no no 4 wins
Now let's eat
Ah ah ah
Kazu-kun is good here
I'm a swimmer I can't have fun playing okay okay okay
[music]
ana